The conquest of Mexico. Yes, it
plagues it took guns. It took steel,
but as the Spanish admitted would have
gone very differently without languages.
1510 mezo America, Audi's to spoke
Maya and lived in a small kingdom,
run by its own real man. Seriously. A
local mine leader was a holiday week.
A real man west of the Maya.
Many people spoke many languages from
many language families will domi support
tech Turtleneck,
but one group's been taking over.
You know who straight from the Valley
of Mexico where the triple alliance,
you dare not defy us. The Aztecs,
their empire was built around.
I've Tippett city states each one
led by Inc Latwonda the speaker,
but one I'll tip it stood above the rest.
They know which deet land.
A huge city floating on a lake,
home of high temples,
human sacrifice and the Aztec
empires way eat [inaudible].
Great Speaker.
The current way [inaudible] is
Martech Soma Montezuma to you.
He demands tribute from all of this
area or else or else flush Gulen.
Their name may start with a very Aztec,
but make no mistake clash.
Scala is a proud and independent
warrior state. Pay Up to him.
We'll take Soma and rest easy.
Stay free,
but constantly watch your back for as
take obsidian. Flesh color says bring it.
I keep saying as tech,
but let's talk names as text means all
people from the legendary homeland Aztlan
at least it doesn't. The Aztec
language linguists call that language.
Know what TL and the related peoples are.
No one,
but that's just a way to say
speaking clearly for their part.
The epic as ticks of Aztec Empire fame
called themselves may Shika and their
land was Ms Sheeko, Mexico. The well,
we're over here debating terminology.
The bearded men start to arrive from
the east and events unfold that will
conspire to put now what will end Maya
into the hands of Mexico's conquerors.
1511 a shipwreck Spanish crew washes
up on the coast of the Yucatan and is
captured by Mayans too will survive.
I get it at a fryer and the sailor
get rid of 1513 tubs school.
He's the Halloweeny could gave his name
to Tabasco. The state end, the Chili.
He battles nearby Shika Longo and
take slaves as a reward among them.
Is Malina. Lee and no one girl
who also spoke to on Pal Maya,
the kind of mine in that part of
the Gulf coast, 1517 bearded men,
Cordova lands in the Yucatan,
he's greeted,
warmly welcomed by the Maya success.
Nope. Turns out it's an ambush,
the Spanish retreat, but managed to nab
a mine on the way out. Maybe George Echo,
he'll be there first Mayan translator,
but a rough one and one will never
buy into this whole Spain thing. 1518,
another explorer.
Grehalva takes military junta visit tab
scope who trades gifts and tells tales
of a wonderful land, the west with many
more treasures, a land called Michiko.
The curious Grehalva says, hmm, maybe
I'll stick around a bit, but tubs,
scopes been warned by my and allies to
keep these guys that distance and says,
I think it's time for you
to move along Cuba 1519.
This is where the bearded
men have been sailing from.
One of them just emptied his life
savings to pay for boats and crew to um,
explore the fabled riches of
Mexico in Non Cortez Cortez sales.
Tuku Samil Cozumel and sends out Middle
Georgia who to track down those two
shipwreck survivors, the sailor,
well, he's gone for good, not dead.
Turns out he went full lion. Seriously,
he became a champion warlord,
but the other guy I be loud is still
alive and his heart's still belongs to
Spain.
The fryer's back in action.
My in captivity turned [inaudible]
ladder into a real asset. See,
the Spanish haven't been big on
local languages. Case in point,
they use a word they learn back
in Cuba for every local chief,
they meet Gas Siki. You're a Mayan
Winnick [inaudible] a Mexican plateau.
[inaudible] the weight La 20
of the whole empire gas CK,
but not like he lied. He speaks
junk down. Maya now, well,
it's John Delta outsiders because he has
Aztec word junk. Fairly means foreigner.
We speak clearly. They on the other
hand, they speak like foreigners.
You know what I mean?
The people of Tabasco clearly disagree
because to them it's yokoten correct
language, whether you call it, I get
a lot of speech for inner correct.
Cortez immediately sees his value,
keeps him by his side and makes
him his language, his tongue.
Great time to talk to more
mines, starting with tubs, Kolbe,
but I don't think his town's taking to
the idea of even more bearded men showing
up. Seriously. These guys again, no
thanks. They put up quite a fight,
but with a little mine,
Intel and a big display of horsepower.
This Spanish to feed them in
the battle of settler tubs,
school berries is dead and
hands over a bounty bounty.
That includes that woman tab scrub
captured in 1513 Molly, Natalie,
this woman has a way with words,
not only can she speak with [inaudible],
she knows the Mexican language.
Also too many names.
Malina Lee took a Spanish name,
Donya Medina,
which got translated back into now
what we're with an honorific is suffix.
Seen Marlene scene that came
back into Spanish as Mcglinchey,
which is how she still
remembered in Mexico,
who Cortez now has a strategy.
He and idealabs speak
Spanish to each other.
I get a lot of turns to
Mallinson scene and speaks.
Maya and Mylene seen uses
now what with the Aztecs?
Until she eventually learned Spanish then,
sorry, Aggie life. You're out. Go team.
Laneless. Why the long chain
of communication though?
Why can't I get loud?
Just pick up some Aztec because
classical, now what? And Sean Paul.
Maya come from two completely
distinct language families.
It's like Chinese and English sort of.
See,
there's a unique linguistic mixing
that happened in Mesoamerica,
but that's so cool.
I'll save it for another video with
his linguists always by his side.
Go test begins to unravel the
resentment beneath the surface. See,
I don't know how you pictured it,
but this is not going to be a small band
of Spaniards standing alone against an
empire.
Success hinges on flipping allies.
Lots and lots of allies.
That's where team linguist comes in.
Spain flips the total knacks.
They down play in fighting and
scuttle their own ships to go. All in.
They learn of blush color.
They dare to enter to blush color.
The ferocious flush colon
warriors put up a major fight,
but the Spanish impressed the guest seek
gay and earn themselves a deeply loyal
ally against the Mashika.
The enemy of my enemy is my Maleen seen
flipping towns and butchering others.
This allied crew pushes on to 10 which
deadline knock knock Multex Soma,
and in November of 1519 well,
Dick Soma opens,
they enter the biggest, the most
impressive city they've ever seen.
The weight latony is carried out to them
and team linguists makes history and an
awkwardly gracious meeting between worlds.
We'll Texoma then launches into a flowery
NovoTAL. That's up for interpretation,
but I think we'll come
back to haunt the city.
Take the word for city state from earlier.
I'll tip it.
It literally means water hill.
Now listen to this line from well Texoma.
The Mutsun in motivates Betsy. Matson
and [inaudible] have the same roots,
water and hill plus the same formal
scene at the end of Marlene scene.
It's your water,
Sir and your hills sir.
He symbolically offering
the city to Cortez,
well to master lean shit.
See,
the Aztecs are addressing team linguist
not as Cortez, but as Marlene sin.
They even painted the pair side by side
in their own codices with her as the
speaker from here.
The history of this conquest turns
more tactical than linguistic.
Cortez takes more Texoma hostage months
of puppet ruler broken by a brutal
Spanish attack during the holiday of
Bullsh Scott that unleashes and as tick
uprising, which ends in the
death of Mattec Soma and many,
many Spaniards in allies
as they flee the city.
Regrouping and flush collar team
language secures more reinforcements and
performs a linguistic trick.
See test interpreted Mattec Somas poetic
speech in Matson in both the bed senior
has him handing the empire over.
If Spain was the rifle master that
makes the Aztecs officially, uh,
people in rebellion thus
follows the vengeful recruiting
of even more allies and
the outbreak of a major plague.
The empire shatters into basically a
civil war in central Mexico that implodes
into a final siege on thin watch.
Dateline a seizure that lasts the summer
of 1521 cost hundreds of thousands of
lives and ends with the city in
ruins while demo the final weight.
[inaudible] is spared only to be executed
by Cortez a few years later before his
death. He speaks out
with Aztec defiance. Oh,
captain McGlinchey long have I understood?
Have I known your false words?
Duplicity today in Mexico.
That's the kind of sting that the
name Marlene Shay has Maleen cheese.
You trade your own culture for a taste of
something foreign, but heroes, villains,
or players in a clash
between two great empires,
translators were key in the conquest
of Mexico. Maleen seeing above all,
I'll be back soon to compare as tick
versus my in grammar and in revel.
Peculiar linguistic secret
about Mullin scenes. Mexico,
stick around and subscribe for language.